Hi, I'm Andrea Savage. And I'm about to answer the internet. Watch my show.
I'm sorry. True TV 10:00 PM. Wednesday night.
Um,
all right.
Would you rather sit down with your parents and watch every sexual encounter
you've had or watch your parents' sex tape when they conceived you easy?
Watch my parents' sex tag when they can see it for me,
I feel like it would be a real sensual,
really intense thing that I'd really like to be a part of.
Would you rather lose the sensitivity flavor of your taste buds? Ooh.
Or lose the sensitivity feeling of sex.
Um, who am I having sex with? My husband.
Let me go look. That's a date, I think. Yeah,
right now it's just my husband. Then I'd rather keep my taste buds.
If you were a war general in the civil war and you got the choice of bringing a
T-Rex or modern war tank on your side, what are you taking?
I don't know. Uh, that's such a, uh,
I'll take a T-Rex.
Can you imagine people's like on the they're on the field and I'm just like,
bring out my T-Rex. I, I think we're done here. I think the war is over.
You are the first girl to do this.
I haven't been accused of having balls.
Well, we rather do the first 90% of a blow job or the last 10%
90. Let's be honest.
It's not, it's not that much work when you're good at it.
It doesn't take that long.
Would you take $4 million to be on to catch a predator? No way.
Yeah. I'm ready to ship.
Would you rather walk with a rollerblade on your left shoe for the rest of your
life or having a little person walking in front of you walking slightly slower
than you want to for the rest of your life? Little person has a bad temper.
Both of these are horrible. Uh,
I would definitely rather walk with a roller blade on my left shoe.
Um, I feel like there's a certain just level of uncomfortableness,
but it's not the midget part.
The idea of someone walking slightly too slowly in front of me will make me,
I would kill myself. So then I'd be dead.
So then what's the point of living my life. Wouldn't be long.
That would make me insane.
Let alone if they were in a car driving slightly slowly,
would you rather watch sports or porn upside down for the rest of your life?
But doesn't does a question. I refuse. If you had D one human body part,
what would it be? I mean, these,
the internet boys, the boys. Yeah.
Um, I need something small. I don't want to eat a lot of flesh.
Probably like the little toe.
First of all, I'm not asking to eat a body part.
You have made me answer a question.
I'm not saying some sort of like low hanging fruit,
like some sort of sexual things, but I'm taking the smallest,
the only person who's made sexual, the first girl, no guys can be like.
No, everyone has compared to like a chicken and been like a thigh.
Why did he such a big piece? I could get a little toe down in one swallow.
No, that's gross. So we're not talking about a cat. We're talking about,
I have to get down one human parts. How do you know?
I don't like a toe. I thought you had to taste.
So you know that OSI, if you had to chew into that side.
Eaten in the world, well, you got to cook it and stuff.
You're the first person to make it sexual. Cause like,
it would be easy to say eat a vagina, but you're the first person to be like,
Oh, it's a sexual thing. It was, everyone's gone.
It's very broey around here. I don't know what's going on. Okay.
I don't know why I have this accent here today. I'm going to California.
Would you rather have your mom read your mind during sex or have your girlfriend
boyfriend read your mind? The rest of the time? Like, Oh,
just all the time.
Yeah.
So he can always see your thoughts or your mom can always see your thoughts only
during sex though.
I'll go with my mom during sex. She's a woman.
She's probably thought the same stuff.
I don't want my husband knowing what I'm thinking all the time.
We've been together too long.
If you could die and come back as any inanimate object, what would it be?
Um, Jesus, that's a hard question. Um,
I would probably come back.
I don't know why I was thinking like a portrait and like somebody's house,
like an interesting, but you know what I mean? Like, yeah.
Or like even like in the white house kind of a thing. Well,
just know you'd be witnessed and you get to like hear and see like a lot of
interesting stuff go down. Um,
you have a choice between a sum of money and world peace.
How much money would it take for you to give up world peace?
I'm not giving up world peace.
Everybody has enough.
I have enough money. I'm fine. Or is it all my money taken away? Now I'm broke.
You got $0 world peace or a hundred billion dollars.
I don't need a hundred billion dollars that causes a lot of problems.
Well, a piece or 10, if you're broke, you use like.
Well, if I'm broken, I have to like survive and I've got my kid,
I don't know, a couple hundred thousand for a year.
I mean, she's got to go to private school.